will you abolish the House of Lords
and will it be in your first term?
yes, we do want to abolish the House of Lords.
I don't think anybody can defend the House of Lords.
it's one of the recommendations,
as you know,
in today's report.
what we're going to do after today is now consult on
those recommendations,
test them, and in particular
look at how can they be implemented?
because what I want to do,
to answer your question,
is to make sure that the talking bit,
which is how do we now implement this,
he carries on now,
but by the time we get to the election,
we can get to the delivery bit,
and everything within the
report is intended to be deliverable.
and the discussion will now have is how do we implement?
when do we implement?
how's the Lord
is obviously important,
but the central trust of this is.
well, look, as I say,
there's now a discussion
about when we're going to implement a.
When I asked for the report.
yes, I do. because when I asked Gordon Brown to
set up the commission and do this,
I said, what I want is recommendations
that are capable of being implemented in the first term.